Nhìn chứ lựa của thế tháo ASEAN trong dài đọn năm 2020 tới phát triển trong tâm trong điểm
các 1 thế tháo Olympic và ASEAN cũng như là vì một cậu đồng ASEAN mạnh khỏe
tất cả mọi người đều tham gia thế tháo, thêm cả những người yêu thế trong xá hội
Nó chính là một trong những mục tiêu được nước trụ nhà Việt Nam được ra
khi lần đầu tiên tụ trước hội y quán chức cậu ASEAN về thế tháo lần thứ 4 sau, sau mời sau
và hội y y quán chức ước chưởng ASEAN về thế tháo lần thứ 3, AMA MS
Việt Nam sẽ air đăng cae nhìn trụ nhà dựa chỉ vậy đi về bi phys
hei nước bên ch
Các hồi gị linh quan thế chất nhận của Việt Nam trong cơ chế hợp tác thế thảo Asian,
đúng thời là cơ hội quảng má hình anh đất nước con người và thế thảo Việt Nam.
Gó phần tăng cường tình hư nghỉ, hư biết lẫn nhau và cù nướng tới một công đồng Asian Doan Kết,
phát triển, mình bứng.